Oh god, I’m back, I made it back and I’m
still alive.
That… thing, the Old Man, it had been tormenting
me for months, following me, trapping me God
knows where.
But I’m out now… and yet somehow that’s
just as bad.
Let me explain…
It all really started about a hundred days
ago, I didn’t start keeping a tally of the
days until a little after things started to
get strange.
But if I think back, the first sign happened
on a completely normal day.
I had been stocking up on supplies with my
eldest, Jimmy.
The superstore in town had a limit on how
much you could spend in a single transaction,
so we had to hit up a few different places
for canned food to store in the bunker.
When we got back, my wife Janey said she’d
noticed a stain upstairs.
Sure enough, she pointed it out to me; a slightly
discolored patch on the ceiling above our
bed.
There wasn’t much there at first, it just
looked like a little area of damp, but I promised
I’d have a look at it over the weekend.
No point wasting money on a handyman, I didn’t
think much of it.
I definitely didn’t think of it as anything
to worry about… but I was so, so wrong.
The very next day, I was outside, making a
full inventory of everything in the bunker.
We had everything, all kinds of practical
equipment for any manner of disaster.
Not just food and water, but ropes and tools,
tents and sleeping bags in case my family
and I ever needed to abandon the bunker and
sleep in the wild.
You see, my whole life I’d been sure that
something was coming, that out on the horizon,
the end of the world was waiting.
The way I saw it, if civilization was one
day going to completely collapse, then I needed
to prepare to make sure my family and I made
it through.
Maybe part of it was the fear too, but when
you’re scared of something, you make yourself
ready for it, right?
Anyway, it was while I was listing the food
rations and trying to figure out just how
many months we’d survive on them, when Janey
came in from the house.
“Jake, that stain on the ceiling’s getting
bigger!”
she declared, dragging me back indoors to
show me.
As far as I could see, it hadn’t changed
much since the day before.
The day after that though, that was a different
story.
Janey didn’t have to point it out, I could
clearly tell that something wasn’t right
about that mark on our ceiling.
It wasn’t just bigger, it was leaking.
But not just water, it didn’t seem like
it had come from a leaky pipe somewhere in
the house.
There was a dark, gooey substance, almost
like tar, that looked as if it had bled through
the surface of the ceiling from the floor
above.
Except, that was the weird thing: there was
no floor above, and our bedroom was on the
highest level of the house.
Apart from the attic, of course.
I climbed up on the bed to take a closer look
at the greasy patch that was now the size
of two dinner plates.
Wearing a thick pair of gloves, I reached
up to wipe away some of the muck.
Immediately, I could smell something burning;
the fingers of my glove had started to melt.
I ran into the bathroom, and pushed it off
my hand from the wrist.
By now, this black ooze had started to spread
much further across the ceiling, reaching
to just above our bed.
Janey told me she didn’t feel comfortable
sleeping under whatever that stuff was, after
it had eaten through my gloves.
I told her she didn’t need to worry, it
wasn’t dripping from the ceiling, and we’d
be fine as long as we just didn’t touch
it.
Even then, she still opted to sleep on the
couch.
That night, I had a really weird dream.
I was convinced that I’d woken up in the
middle of the night, restless and uneasy knowing
Janey wasn’t in the bed next to me.
That’s when I looked up at that slick patch
of darkness smeared across the ceiling.
But there was something else there too: a
face, a grotesque face staring down at me,
grinning a wide, lipless smile.
I’m sure it was a dream, it had to be, I’d
been putting off doing anything about the
stain, that’s why I dreamt about it, right?
Or maybe I was awake and it was just a trick
of the light…
“What do you mean you won’t call someone?”
Janey asked indignantly.
“I just don’t see the point!”
I argued.
We had gotten into something of a heated debate
over what to do about the goop on our ceiling.
I’d decided not to tell her about my nightmare,
but even then, she was determined that I get
a handyman or someone to come and take a look
at it.
“It’d be a waste of money,” I tried
to convince her.
“Why should we shell out money for someone
when I can just get some disinfectant and
clean it up myself?”
“Because you don’t know what it is, even
if you could just wipe it off, it might come
back!” she yelled.
“You’d rather try to sort it out quickly
so you can get back to working on your bunker!”
“That’s to keep us safe!”
I retorted.
“Look, Jake.
I’ve humored it for long enough, but you
spend more time out there than looking after
your own house,” Janey sighed.
I refused, I knew it was the stubborn, petty
thing to do, but I had taken Janey’s comments
about my bunker to heart.
She’d never minded before, always understood
that I was only doing it for us.
I think she saw the good place it came from
first, and that meant more than the actual
work I’d done stockpiling supplies and making
sure we’d have working plumbing after the
collapse.
Later that day, I caught both Jimmy and Jake
Jr were lingering at the bedroom door, staring
up at the thick, dark sludge on the ceiling.
The pair of them were both keeping themselves
behind the doorframe or gripping the door
itself like a shield.
My boys were scared of it, it was clear as
day.
“Dad, is the house sick?”
Jake Jr asked.
“Houses don’t get sick,” his older brother
interjected.
“It’s haunted…
there’s a monster in the attic, right Dad?”
“No monsters and the house isn’t sick,”
I replied, forcing a smile to my sons.
“I’ll take care of it.”
About a week after the stain had first appeared,
it was time for the monthly drill.
Every four weeks, I’d gather my family and
we’d do a little practice just in case the
worst should happen.
At the sound of an air horn, we’d all have
to grab the bug out bags I’d prepared for
everyone, and run out to the bunker in under
five minutes.
The boys were always eager, it helped that
they were both young enough that we could
treat it like a game.
Janey, though, she didn’t want to get involved
in this drill.
She stayed indoors, trying to play it off
to the kids as if she was just busy.
But the side glance she shot at me said different,
and it was hard to avoid the guilt that came
with it.
That, coupled with seeing the boy’s reaction
to it, convinced me that it would just be
easier to have someone come take a look at
the slimy patch above the bed.
I’d needed to go to town the next day, another
supply run, so I picked up the number of a
repair guy while I was out, even called him
on the way home, thinking that would make
it up to Janey.
But as I pulled up to the driveway, I could
hear screaming coming from the house.
I raced indoors and that’s when I saw my
wife, standing between our two boys and…
it.
It was like a desiccated corpse, an Old Man
with viscous black grease leaking out of his
decaying body.
The same substance that had pooled on our
bedroom ceiling… and was now covering Janey.
The Old Man had her arm gripped in his body
hand, the same fluid coating her skin and
burning her.
She was shrieking in pain, tears running down
her face as the boys cowered behind her.
I froze, I had no idea what to do… so I
ran.
I had acted out of panic, and spent the next
week regretting it deeper than any mistake
I’d ever made.
I’d left my bugout bag in the house and
just blindly sprinted straight for the bunker
while the screams of my wife and kids filled
the house.
In the days that followed, everything fell
quiet, but even then, I barely slept.
Through a porthole in the heavy metal door,
I watched the rear of my home.
Occasionally I’d catch sight of movement
inside, some tiny bit of motion, usually at
night.
I kept hoping it would be Janey, or one of
the boys, having found a place to hide and
then making their way out the back door to
me.
But every time, it was only ever him.
The Old Man slunk through my family’s home,
staring out at me with lidless eyes, his jaw
locked in a twisted grin like he was enjoying
tormenting me.
A sharp knock on the bunker door woke me up
from the short, restless sleep.
I sat bolt upright, immediately expecting
that thing to be on the other side.
It was the handyman I’d called a few days
earlier – it seemed like such a trivial
matter now.
“There was no answer at the front,” he
explained to me.
“Hope you don’t mind me coming around
the back, your side gate was open.”
Barely paying him any mind, I dashed towards
the house.
There was no sign of the Old Man, but I couldn’t
find Janey’s body, or the two boys’ anywhere.
I went to grab my bugout bag, only to run
into the handyman in the hallway.
Before I could urge him to run, to leave the
house, the Old Man’s face appeared, pushing
through another slick, oily black puddle in
the wall, grabbing the other man and dragging
him in as I bolted for the door.
Heading for the woods was my safest option
– no, my only option.
If I went to the police, there was no way
they’d believe such an outlandish story.
They’d probably suspect me of murdering
my family, or think I was crazy if I told
them a zombie had attacked my home.
That got me thinking, what the hell was that
Old Man?
He couldn’t have been a zombie, for a start
there was only one and he wasn’t turning
people.
But there was something off about his actions,
almost like they weren’t mindless shuffling
and attacks.
There was an intent behind them.
He was patient.
Camping out in the woods brought me no joy,
even with all the supplies in my bag.
Whenever I tried to sleep, I’d just lay
awake for hours, thinking of my family…
and the grotesque face of the Old Man.
Every sound in the night – the wind rustling
leaves, animals cracking sticks underfoot
– in my mind, everything I heard was him
getting closer and closer.
And pretty soon he did.
I started keeping watch during the nights,
and I’d catch sight of a silhouetted figure
in the darkness.
Every few days, he would reappear.
He’d never get close enough to attack me,
just enough to force me to pack up camp again
and relocate.
Until one night, I could hear the sound of
gurgled breathing outside my tent.
I reached for my flashlight, casting its light
over the walking corpse that stood outside.
It recoiled from the bright light, but as
its decaying face illuminated, I ran, leaving
my campsite and bag where they were.
I didn’t care, I just sprinted through the
woods, branches scratching at me like the
decrepit bony fingers of the Old Man clawing
at my skin.
I could hear water running, barely seeing
the stream in my flashlight before my foot
sank into it.
Wading through, I crawled out on the opposite
bank, cold, wet, and still trying to get away.
The days that followed were hard, with no
supplies I had to survive on what little I
had left in my pockets.
My best bet, I thought, was to keep hiking,
keep putting distance between myself and him.
And for a while, it was working… or I thought
it was.
It wasn’t until I came across tracks, not
like animal tracks, not even an ordinary human’s
footprints.
They were thick with that black, burning tar,
melting into the forest ground in the shape
of the Old Man’s foot.
I’d gone around in a circle.
The whole time I thought I was getting away
from him, I had just been going around and
around.
When I stumbled upon what was still left of
my campsite, I should have been overjoyed,
but instead, my heart dropped through to the
bottom of my stomach.
I shouldn’t have stopped there, that was
what he wanted.
But I was hungry, exhausted, and just needed
to sleep.
That was when he got me, I woke up to the
stench of some burning substance, only to
find something locked tightly around my ankle;
one of the Old Man’s hands.
Another of his greasy gateways had opened
on a nearby tree, and he was pulling me inside.
The pain was what hit me first, before I could
even get a good look at where I was or what
was around me.
Instead, all I felt was the most excruciating
agony I’d ever experienced.
Looking down, I saw why.
The Old Man had two of his bony, clawed fingers
hooked into my ankle.
Not just holding me by it, his fingers were
going through and it hurt.
The black sludge was still dripping from him
and onto me.
The more of it passed through my clothes,
touched my skin, and mixed with my blood,
the more I felt it burning.
Digging in the fingers of his other hand,
the Old Man pulled apart the bones in my lower
leg like the wishbone of a turkey, only with
a much louder and far more painful snap.
The shock left me unconscious again, lost
and now with half of my leg forcibly ripped
away.
I had no idea where I was, and for some strange
reason the Old Man had left me to wander around
freely.
Although I’d soon find out why.
It hurt just to move, but I wrapped my leg
up and crawled my way around the vast labyrinth.
Even if I still had my bag, which had a compass
in it, it still would have been impossible
to navigate.
I tried to take shelter under my jacket, hiding
and setting up as much of a camp as I could.
Every time I thought I was safe, a greasy
black puddle would begin to form on the nearest
wall, and that same decaying face with the
lipless grin came through it.
But that was why he let me wander, just so
he could make sure I never slept; my suffering
was a game to him.
The longer I spent there, the more tired I
became.
Through lack of sleep, searing pain of my
forcibly amputated leg, and the fear of trying
to keep away from the Old Man, I started to
get low.
I had no way of escaping.
Even if I tried stepping through one of those
black puddles, it would just corrode me.
But I started to think, maybe that would’ve
been better.
Getting home meant having to live without
Janey.
She would still be gone, Jimmy and Jake Jr
weren’t going to be waiting for me if I
somehow managed to make it back.
I had been keeping a tally of the days since
I’d left, adding on the week when the stain
first appeared.
It had been ninety days.
I couldn’t take anymore.
I just wanted it over.
I didn’t see the point to continuing this
torture, I wanted to leave and I wanted my
family back.
The only way to get both was to let the Old
Man get me.
But he must’ve known I was looking for him,
every time I yelled out into the confusing
maze I was stuck in, I never got an answer.
He wouldn’t come and find me.
I couldn’t tell if he knew how badly I was
suffering stuck here and just wanted to prolong
that, or if he’d gotten bored of me.
Eventually, after over another week without
rest, I tried to sleep again.
And that was when he came for me.
Only I didn’t bother to run this time, as
I saw the corpse-like creature shambling towards
me, black grease covering its body.
I closed my eyes and waited for it to happen.
When I came back to consciousness, my vision
was filled with nothing but bright, white
light.
I thought that maybe this was it, that the
Old Man had caught me and decided to put an
end to the chasing and torture.
For a brief few seconds, I was certain that
I was dead.
What else are you supposed to think when you
wake up squinting at a blinding light?
But I wasn’t dead and hadn’t been delivered
to the afterlife.
And I wasn’t still in that horrible labyrinth,
that nightmarish place I had just been for
over a month.
Feeling the cold, hard ground, something in
the pit of my stomach told me I was back in
the real world.
Still unable to see properly, I raised a hand
to block out some of the glare, the sounds
of heavy boots clomping towards me.
Two pairs of gloved hands reached out and
grabbed my arms, dragging me out of the path
of the intense light.
As they did, I started blinking away the spots
in my vision, and that’s when I saw masses
of machinery and the creature, the Old Man
caught in the beams of three white spotlights.
I looked up at the people who had saved me,
a pair of figures in tactical gear, their
uniforms bearing the insignia of something
called the ‘SCP Foundation’.
As grateful as I was to this Foundation for
pulling me out of that nightmare, and as glad
as I was to still be alive, I couldn’t help
but feel more and more uneasy as they debriefed
me.
Maybe it was just how interested they seemed
in my encounter with the Old Man – or SCP-106,
as they called it – as I described what
had happened in a lengthy debrief.
Or it might have been how quick they were
to shrug off what the Old Man had done to
my family.
Whatever it was, I didn’t trust them, even
though they seemed to believe my story.
Recalling it all made me think of Janey and
my two boys again.
I used to be so afraid of the world ending,
spent all that time and money making sure
I was ready for when the end finally hit.
But it had snuck up on me, it didn’t matter
that the Earth was still turning, my world
was gone.
And, I figured, that must have been why the
Old Man kept me alive.
It could’ve easily killed me if it really
wanted to, but it let me live on, not just
so it could torture me, but so I’d be alive
to know my family were gone.
It wasn’t long after I realized this that
the Foundation offered me something, medicine
they said would help me forget about it all.
If I didn’t take it, I’d at least get
to remember what I used to have, but also
live with the pain of not having it anymore.
That was the Old Man’s real torture... so
I had to.
As I washed down the pill with a swig of water,
I thought back to Janey and my sons with tears
in my eyes, wishing them goodbye before they
were really gone forever.
Now go and check out “SCP-106 CONTAINMENT
BREACH” and “SCP-106 CAUSED A SCHOOL LOCKDOWN”
for further background information on this
sadistic and sinister anomaly, as well as
a few other situations unsuspecting victims
found themselves being hunted by the Old Man...
and whether or not they too lived to tell
about it.